here's a report from an outlet called
Atlanta news first uh in Georgia
obviously about a restaurant that has
created controversy because of a fee
that they have passed down for bad
parenting Let's uh watch a little bit of
this I know Georgia restaurant going
viral on social media for having what's
called a parent sir charge on their menu
this is pretty interesting the charge
according to the restaurant is for
adults who can't parent their children
Atlanta news first reporter Amanda Rose
spoke to the restaurant today on ASA
Road in Blue Ridge after a bad online
review sparked a national
conversation I've never left a review in
my life of a business when I left there
we were leaving reviews Brian garolo is
still in disbelief after what he calls a
nightmare experience at tcoa Riverside
Restaurant in Blue Ridge the restaurant
now gaining national attention for onear
reviews left by Caro's friends online
who say the restaurant wanted them to
pay extra for bad parenting he basically
said he has raised his children he's not
going to raise ours carolo a restaurant
owner who lives in Central Florida says
five families including his own visited
the restaurant on vacation with 11
children all under the age of eight
after finishing their meal carolo says
someone from the restaurant made a
surprise visit to their table saying the
group should pay a parent search charge
the fee is listed on the Restaurant's
menu next to $3 signs in the words
unable to parent carolo says he thought
it was a joke the owner tells me he's
had this parent search charge on the
menu since the pandemic but he's never
had to enforce it on any of his
customers he wants to emphasize that the
charge is not for kids but for adults
who don't know how to parent the
restaurant says they never charge carcio
in the other others the fee but they
told us the group had to be quote really
bad for them to bring it up at all a
representative for the restaurant went
on to say there's nothing wrong with
kids and families coming to the
restaurant but kids running wild through
the dining room is so you get the basic
idea uh I'll admit that's a good line I
raised my own kids I'm not going to
raise yours let's try to sort through
this uh we have the restaurant saying
that kids are running wild we have the
parents saying the restaurant owners are
rude and nasty and that their kids are
not running wild but they're being
discriminated against you know because
they just because they have a large
family so we'll try to figure this out
the first point is that one of these
angry reviews from a parent says that
the owner told them that it is a fancy
restaurant and you can't have kids
acting up in a fancy restaurant but it's
actually an important point that like we
saw the outside of this place that ain't
fancy okay like when you have an ATM
sign outside of your restaurant that
that's a Telltale sign that it is not a
fancy place when there's a sign that
says ice cream and t-shirts which there
is outside that but and Candy they have
a sign saying candy outside of the way
that is a that's a very good indication
that it's not a fancy place in fact as a
parent if I am in an unfamiliar area
looking for somewhere to eat with my
kids that's the kind of thing I'm
looking for to tell me that it is a
family-friendly non-fancy place if I'm
driving by an i that place and my kids
are hungry and I'm just visiting and I
don't know what's around and I see that
place I'm like oh yeah this is we're all
day this is this is where we need to be
I mean this is obviously a place where
you could bring your family um this is
not a fancy place you could just tell
from the outside and and um so you just
can't have a place like that and then
expect that people won't bring their
kids it's like it's like opening up a
mini golf course and then getting
annoyed when a bunch of kids show up
it's what did you expect the holidays
are coming up fast F while you're out
shopping for your kids family and
friends don't forget to shop for your
pets too give your dog the gift of a
healthier and happier life with rough
greens naturopathic Dr Dennis black the
founder of rough greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America before I started feeding my dog
Ruff greens I had no idea the dog food
is dead food it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dogs food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food just sprinkle Ru Greens on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels and so much
more we are what we eat and that goes
for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident Ru greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so your dog can tral that's a free jump
start trial bag delivered straight to
your door in just a few business days go
to Ru greens.com mat or call 844 ru700
that's our FFG greens.com or call 844
ru700
today and this is a point for customers
too by the way because there are certain
kinds of diners who get very annoyed
sharing a restaurant with
children and that and fine if you know
if that's how you feel
fine but the point is you can certainly
avoid kids at a restaurant you just need
to go to a place where the Entre are $25
or more on average per plate okay
probably even $20 or more per plate is
enough um no kids menu you know 20 $30
Entre guarantee you're going to see very
few kids in a place like that because
that's just you're not going to bring
your family I'm not going to bring my my
kids to I'm not spending
$200 on a on a family dinner so if you
want to avoid kids pay up go to a more
expensive place go to an actual nice
restaurant and then you can uh it'll be
it be it'll be kid-free pretty much at
any time of day but you can't can't go
to an affordable place and then get mad
when families are there because those
places are for us mainly what where else
do you expect us to go we got are we not
supposed to go to any
restaurants now that said if these
families were actually being obnoxious
if the kids were running wild then sure
I support the owners putting their foots
foot down um letting your kids run
around a restaurant is crazy most
parents don't do that I've I've very
rarely seen anything like that at a
restaurant I've been in many restaurants
where
where there are kids and I've very
rarely seen kids literally running
around the restaurant like it's a jungle
gym every once in a while but it's
pretty uh rare
occurrence and if that happens then uh
then then yeah I think for the owner to
say something is is perfectly fine but
here's my question why don't you
have uh a search charge for obnoxious
people okay why not have a r a a rule
that if your table is disrupted Ive then
you will be charged more A disruption
fee I'd be I not only would I be fine
with that I would love to e at a place
that has a rule like that I I'm I would
support I'd go to that place every week
okay I'd give that place money even if
I'm not eating there okay just a
donation um and I've been in plenty of
restaurants and other public situations
where adults are being disruptive and
obnoxious that happens too all the time
so my question is why are you singling
out parents why not just if you have a
issue with people being disruptive just
it's a disruptive table we charge you a
fee doesn't matter why you're being dis
doesn't matter if it's a kid an
adult
whatever so the fact that they're
singling out parents that tells me that
this guy really does just have a problem
with kids he wants to have his cheap
restaurant with the ATM machine and ice
cream and t-shirts and Candy but he
doesn't really want families uh even
though without families his place would
go bankrupt so
ultimately he is the it's turned into an
MI I guess hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there